i susan parsonage acting returning
officer for the lancaster and fleet word
parliamentary constituency declare that
the total number of votes given to each
candidate was as follows
Robin Eamonn long Liberal Democrats
1117
[Music]
Rebecca joy Novell 796
[Applause]
Eric Halloran Shaw the Conservative
Party candidate 18,000 681
[Applause]
Catherine Jane Smith Labour Party 25,000
[Applause]
I gave public notice that Katherine Jane
Smith is duly elected as the Member of
Parliament for the Lancaster and fleet
word constituency the total number of
votes cast across Lancaster and
Fleetwood at the UK parliamentary
election on 8th of June 2017 was 46,000
and 82 the total number of ballot papers
rejected was 93 the ballot papers were
rejected for the following reasons one
was rejected because it did not bear the
official mark 13 ballot papers were
rejected because votes were given to
more than one candidate for pilot papers
were rejected because there was
something written or marked on the
ballot paper by which the voter could be
identified and 75 ballot papers were
rejected because they were unmarked or
void from certainty congratulations to
you
[Applause]
I'm incredibly grateful to the voters of
Lancaster and Fleetwood who place their
trust in me once more and I hope to
repay the trust in serving as your
Member of Parliament and working hard
entirely for our community results like
this and others across the country show
that voters are increasingly turning
against the failed conservative dogma we
seized cuts to our NHS schools and
public services and which is seen wages
fail to keep up with prices rejected
this racism button which sees the many
pay the price for the perks of the few
the voters in our community and many
others across the country have chosen
the politics of Hope over the politics
of fear and division I would like to
thank the police and the returning
officer and council staff for the
running of this election and the count
I'd like to thank my agent and my
wonderful campaign team and all those
hundreds of people who came out and
volunteered across this constituency I'd
like to thank the voters and everybody
who took part in the democratic process
including the candidates and campaign
team from the other parties to everybody
who takes part in our democracy thank
you